good morning Hank it's Tuesday good
morning John oh it's a surprise reunion
video who would have guessed it I would
never I didn't even know I was here all
right I have some questions for you
first question how many potatoes did the
average Irish person eat per day in 1844
do many guests or yeah no for sure I
want you to guess I'm gonna say 6:45
wait what's the average Irish person in
1844 man woman and child average human
ate nine pounds of potatoes per day and
can you really grow potatoes on Mars not
the way they did in the movie okay but
yes other ways do you want to get into
it a little bit all right well you got
some serious problems with Martian soil
mmm it's got perchlorate in it which is
a big big issue because that's toxic to
humans and also plants okay uh if you
can get that out if you can get some of
the other bad stuff out and you can put
in some good stuff yeah you can you can
group potato some marshmallow even
without an atmosphere oh no you'd have
to build a thing around it you have to
build it out this year yeah did you know
the potatoes were responsible for at
least 25 percent of Europe's population
growth between 1700 and 1900 noticing a
trend here what's the trend potatoes
seems to be the trend in this question
Tuesday video it's weird
I just got a lot of potato questions I
don't know why I also didn't know that I
and I bet there's a crash-course video
there is you can watch the Columbian
Exchange crash course video currently on
hex-head okay if you could create
anything with potatoes what would it be
a man fully a sentient being like mr.
Potato Head
they already did that they are now is
that it's in choice but I want to I
wanted to be a thinking feeling potato
man have you not seen Toy Story please
name three potatoes um the russet yeah
the purple yep the goldie hawn that's a
good potato name that they haven't done
that they should have they said they
should why isn't there a potato named
after Goldie Hawn she's an American
treasure hey can you rename one of your
favorite books by replacing one word
with potato red potato The Fault and our
potatoes the Lord of the potatoes I hate
that
I mean both the Lord of the Flies and
the warden is talking about the Lord of
the Rings oh I have to teach order the
Flies this year in crash course
literature and I just openly revile the
book so I want to be very chat will be
very interesting I'm quite fond of their
eyes were watching potatoes this is a
good question uh which of you has a
better potato impression you know
potatoes have eyes just like humans not
just like you couple questions not
related to potatoes Hank oh sorry to do
that for you I'm completely unprepared
for this uh what's the opposite of
potato that is a potato question Henry
you know the opposite of potato is the
opposite of potato is the vacuum of
space I was going to say that the
opposite of potato is a boysenberry
actual non potato related question Hank
are you stressed about the presidential
race oh god yes what is your favorite
One Direction song yeah
Henry's favorite song is fire all boom
which is what he calls boon for all the
Swedish hip-hop song on the fall nurse
are seven-track Hank what do you prefer
potato pizza or pizza
potato potato pizza I also like potato
pizza it's an old favorite of mine
underappreciated pizza yeah actually
I've had a lot of good potato pizzas in
the western montana fair they have a
thing called a tater Pig mm-hmm potato
pig is just a hollowed-out potato with a
hotdog shoved in it it's not very good
all right Hank thank you for
participating in question Tuesday Hank
I'll see you on Friday
what